hello everybody thank you so much for
tuning in today
before we get started quick disclaimer
everything I share here is my personal
opinion and Google is not responsible
for any content opinions expressed by me
content use is a fully non-confidential
with that out of the way little bit
about me I am Niha bansal and I've been
in product for more than a decade you
can find all the boring details on
LinkedIn the interesting part is that
about a year ago I moved to an early
stage team within Google so at this
point my Google product along with a few
startups that I had invested in were
trying to get their brand new product
off the ground
that's when I started reading books
meeting people to understand how do you
get a product off the ground and find
product Market fit in that Journey a
senior director at Google recommended
Andrew Chen's book the cold start
problem
it was such an enlightening moment
because it disentangled many theoretical
Concepts and gave me a framework for
taking things from zero to one and
that's what I'm here to share with you
all today
let's make sure you are also the right
uh you're here for the right reasons you
are all early stage Founders or product
owners product managers at various sized
companies looking to start something new
literally from a blank slate
with that let's start let's dive into
the cold start Theory
Andrew Chen introduced this Theory as a
framework to think about different
stages of a business
cold start Theory lays out a series of
stages that every product team must
Traverse to fully harness the power of
network effects
the primary five stages are first is the
cold start once you solve the cold start
problem you hit a Tipping Point
post that you find an escape velocity
hitting the ceiling and once you hit the
ceiling you find a moat at which you
continue to maintain
I do wish that the framework had a
different name because it's the same
name as the first stage of the whole
Theory which could be a bit confusing
but never mind for our purpose we will
focus on what needs to happen to go from
the first stage of the whole from the
first stage to the second stage visually
we will talk about this Red Dot
which needs to happen somewhere on the
lower side of this graph meaning you
need to solve the cold start problem to
find product Market fit and then you can
grow and grow until you hit the Tipping
Point
so how do you solve the cold start
problem
well that's the first uh well the first
step to solving the cold start problem
is identifying and building an atomic
Network
a network of users which is stable
engaged and can self-sustain Andrew
defines it as the smallest possible
Network that is stable and can grow on
its own once you have such a network you
have found a product Market fit
let's crystallize this concept with some
examples
any guesses on how Facebook first got
started
well Facebook Sports Atomic network was
College communities the first they first
got success at Harvard University where
Mark was and then expanded rapidly
moving to other Boston area schools and
rest of the ivy league that spring
uh let's take another example of uber
Uber started with 5 PM commuters at San
Francisco Caltrain station at 4th and
King Street I absolutely love the
specificity here
with Airbnb their atomic network was
Travelers attending conferences that
cause shortage of hotels hotel rooms in
that city which meant large conferences
another fun example is slack Slack's
Atomic network with three people teamed
within a company
each of these products had to identify
what the appropriate Atomic network was
for them in order to find the product
Market fit in its early stage
there's another uh you know fun example
and I think that's my favorite Atomic
Network story which is uh about credit
cards so Bank of America launched is the
company that launched the first credit
card and the city that they chose to do
that was in Fresno California
now you might be wondering why did they
go so narrow and why did they choose
Fresno California
well
on the demand side 35 of Fresno
residents already had some relationship
with the bank and on the supply side
most small businesses in Fresno downtown
did not have a proprietary charge card
which was a thing back in the 1950s
so with that information they prioritize
they focused on Fresno and then on one
specific day the credit cards arrived in
the mailbox of 60 000 Fresno residents
no application process ready to use
these residents use the cards at the 300
merchants in Fresno downtown and boom
they got the traction they needed to
approve product Market fit
I hope uh you know I hope you're
enjoying these examples and if you're
not yet convinced let me give you some
lesser known examples but they're very
close to heart for me
first is homejoy homejoy is Kim
Spalding's company that focus on
matching professionals like electricians
Carpenters Etc to homeowners when they
started their atomic network was
locksmiths just locksmiths
once they've got product Market fit by
matching locksmiths to homeowners they
expanded to cleaners and electricians
and the rest is history they proved
product Market fit again and again and
eventually got acquired by Google to
become the foundation of the Google
local Services product
another fun example is Google's shopping
for businesses this is my project which
is very close to my heart because I
worked on it so we started with building
a Marketplace for everyone everyone
being a business that needs to buy
something electricals Plumbing cleaning
material handling arborists lawyers
retailers
obviously not surprisingly initially we
didn't see any traction
that's when we said okay we're doing
this wrong so we pivoted to focus just
on one vertical at that time we chose
Plumbing for a variety of reasons and
suddenly numbers started looking good
I'll share one final example with you of
circles
circles were started by a very good
friend and uh the vision early on was
they wanted to build Tick Tock for
LinkedIn professionals
turns out this was too broad after lots
of iterations the team accepted that
they need to focus find their atomic
Network
they decided to focus on law firms as an
atomic Network because turns out that
they have Deep Pockets and horrible
digital marketing skills
as I was going on and on about these
examples with a good friend Paul gibell
by the way he hosts an amazing podcast
called Product momentum he asked me that
why are you talking about going small
when everyone talks about scale like why
go small
so in 2010 I read an essay by Chris
Dixon he's a partner at Andresen
Horowitz he wrote an essay titled the
next big thing will start out looking
like a toy when he talks about the
disruptive technology Theory which says
that disruptive Technologies are
dismissed as toys because when they are
first launched they undershoot user
needs for example the first telephone
could only carry voices a mile or two
the leading Telco of the time Western
Union passed on acquiring the phone
because they didn't see how it could
possibly be useful to businesses and
railroads their primary customers
what they failed to anticipate was how
rapidly telephone technology and
infrastructure would improve
the same was true of how Mainframe
companies viewed the PC and how modern
telecon companies viewed Skype
Andrew extends this into target audience
the next big thing will start out
looking like it's for a niche Network
but the questions Still Remains why go
small
well the answer is that the more user
you need the harder it is to create
something that's why starting off with a
group of users has that is small allows
you to analyze root causes of what's not
working you can pick up the phone and
call the user and ask like hey why
aren't you signing up what's stopping
you from doing that help me understand
but imagine doing that if you launch
something to everybody whom would you
talk to First
okay so with that I hope we're all
aligned on the power of the atomic
networks and what is it and why should
we focus on that the next question is
how do you build such an atomic Network
I'm going to try to summarize that in
three steps first step is identify the
hard side of the network
this is the these are the minority of
the users that create disproportionate
value and as a result have
disproportionate power
for example content creators for social
network drivers for Uber Developers for
app store managers that create documents
and projects for workspace apps for
marketplaces it would be sellers for
Wikipedia it would be volunteers who
write all the articles
this is the hard site these are the hard
side of the network
identify your hard side and once you
have done that solve hard problems for
this hard side of the users
you have to think about a lot of
questions such as what is the unique
value proposition for this side how will
they use the product how do they first
hear about your product and in what
context why will they come back more
frequently and become more engaged what
makes them sticky to their Network such
that when a new network emerges they
will retain on your product
these are difficult answers and require
a deep understanding of the motivations
of your users
understanding these diverse points of
view make it easier to serve them
and finally develop a simple to use
killer product that solves the problem
and ultimately deliver a magic moment to
these users remember your product should
not be fully featured because you want
it to be a dead simple value proposition
while you're doing all this ignore all
questions around what is the market size
how scalable is your idea or how will
you monetize it Etc your focus should be
on getting traction with your Atomic
Network use growth hacks do whatever it
takes to get the small group of users
sticky
so yeah when I say small how small am I
really talking about
studying all the examples I have I'd say
maybe 100 users at a specific Moment In
Time create Magic Moment for these users
uh special for Consumer products
now let's say you have already done this
how did you know if you have succeeded
in creating those magic moments for your
Atomic Network
well Magic Moment is a nice concept but
it would be even more useful if you
could measure it the best way to do this
might be even more surprising
so you start with the opposite of Magic
the moments where the network was broken
down and then start solving the problem
from there
first Define your zero moments
for example when Uber started at the
Caltrain station they gave their drivers
and coordinators an app I think it was
called Starcraft that recorded the right
completion so anytime a rider didn't
match with a driver it was recorded as a
zero they continuously iterated to
completely eliminate these zero moments
so Define your zero moments monitor them
and finally get them down to zero
and that's how my friends product Market
fit is achieved when a product starts
generating magical moments with minimal
zeros you can claim to have found
product Market fit
well I know we're all uh data hungry
people here so let's define this in
commonly used metrics in our world
typically the best metric for pmf would
be retention which you would analyze
using time-based cohorts
um I was able to find some interesting
benchmarks as well for Consumer and SAS
products so let's go over those quickly
for Consumer products you would want to
see a daily active user to monthly
active user ratio of 25 and above a
world-class leading down would be over
50 percent
there's a certain minimum for organic
acquisition so you would want to see
hundreds if not thousands of signups per
day
in terms of retention day one retention
should be at least 30 percent 70 plus
would be top-notch
for SAS products you would look at these
engagement metrics and also some
additional monetization metrics such as
five percent conversion rate when you
when your user goes from free to paid
the three times GPA to LTB ratio monthly
churn should be less than two percent
and there should be a clear path to 100
000 of monthly recurring Revenue
I hope that helps um
now obviously this all seems very clear
so why do many startup projects and
companies fail to find product Market
fit
well from my personal experience the
hardest thing about going so small is to
commit
in my product where
I was building a B2B Marketplace
we chose to focus on Plumbing now that
was scary for the merchant onboarding
team initially because they felt that
they will not be able to find enough
companies that wants to sell Plumbing
products
it's always a hard mindset shift
also commitment involved saying no many
many times for every feature idea I had
I would have to think that do plumbing
businesses uh would they need this if no
I'm not building it right now and doing
that was absolutely difficult
and finally in a team setup constantly
reminding the team that this is just the
first leg we will go beyond this I would
be asked all the time so are we now a
plumbing Marketplace and then you would
uh you have you are the one who has to
remind the team that this is just where
we're getting started we will be going
Beyond
so um in a nutshell I think having a lot
of self-control and commitment to only
build for what is needed by that small
atomic network is the hardest part
so
let's say you found product Market fit
in your first atomic Network so what's
next
well
I suggest that you document your success
Playbook write down what worked for you
and what did not and what did you do to
fix those problems
once you've done that you rinse and
repeat do it again and again
going back to the Uber example Uber
found their product Market fit at the
Caltrain station at 4th and King Street
once they did that they used the same
Playbook to expand to nearby stations
and eventually to the whole of San
Francisco city and the rest of Bay Area
and the rest of the world
doing writing down your playbook helps
you rinse and repeat and move at a much
faster pace
and you keep doing this until you hit
your Tipping Point
if there is one thing I want you to take
away from today it is this slide
when you get back to work on your sort
of project write down the definition of
your Atomic Network for example who is
your user group what is the intent in
location and time
so let's say if you are a project
management application your Atomic
Network could be a product team at Chase
Bank who wants to plan for let's say the
Q2 cycle right be as specific as you can
with that thank you so much everyone for
tuning in if you're interested in
hearing more from me you are welcome to
sign up for my newsletter and follow me
on LinkedIn also I highly recommend this
book from Andrew Chen called the cold
start problem
have a great rest of your week and
thanks again